we've talked about how more and more
Republicans have been opting to retire
and not seek reelection rather than risk
being taken out maybe by a Democrat
maybe by a non Trump affiliated
Republican and this is all as a result
of the damage that Trump has done to the
Republican Party we've seen a number of
Republicans say they're not going to run
for re-election this morning we learned
that this phenomena goes all the way to
the very very top because Republican
Speaker of the House Paul Ryan the third
in command in the United States
political hierarchy is not running for
re-election and of course Ryan is
telling a very very positive story
saying he's leaving Republicans in good
hands he's had twenty years it's a good
run he wants to spend more time with his
kids but this is not like the beautiful
riding into the sunset that Paul Ryan is
trying to portray and there is every
indication here that there is major may
Anakin the Republican Party and the
decision even surprised many Republicans
that Paul Ryan wasn't going to be
running for re-election as soon as Paul
Ryan announced which was broken earlier
today Republican congressman Dennis Ross
of Florida also said he is going to be
retiring and Speaker of the House is
just not a position you bail on if it
appears that you've got sort of a clear
sailing path to maintain it and that
doesn't mean that Paul Ryan's
explanations aren't valid right I'm sure
he wants to spend more time with his
family
I think his daughter was like an early
teenager when he became Speaker of the
House and you know I totally get it
right he wants to spend time with his
family he has been in there 20 years but
most people would decide to stick it out
just a little bit longer if they have a
clear opportunity to make it another
couple of years in a position of such
power and it isn't even clear that
Republicans are going to maintain the
house at all never mind Paul Ryan in his
specific seat and if they did maintain
control of the house in the midterm
election would it be a productive
context for such a beleaguered to borrow
a word from Trump a beleaguered Speaker
of the House in the sense that many
trumpets aren't loving what Paul Ryan
has be doing been doing
very interesting midterm and actually I
don't know if you've been following the
iron stash of Bryce
Randy Bryce Randy Bryce is a Democrat
who's running against Paul Ryan in his
district in Wisconsin it was
understandably sort of a longshot
candidacy Bryce was building momentum
and he has growing name recognition
within within the district but running
now rather than against Paul Ryan
running against or in an open seat
election in Wisconsin is a very very
different scenario and if you're in
Wisconsin and you're thinking about
getting involved in a race there it
would be an amazing victory to not only
take out a Republican seat but the one
previously held by the Speaker of the
House the retiring Speaker of the House
and bring that back to Democratic
control so we'll be watching that
particular race
I will also be watching sort of the
ripple effect over the next two or three
weeks of more Republicans saying you
know I want to be with family or I want
to move on to private law practice or
become a lobbyist or whatever the case
may be I would predict in the next two
to three two to four weeks you're going
to see even more Republicans sort of put
their finger in the wind and feel the
direction that things are going and join
Paul Ryan in this and and as I mentioned
trumpets might not actually be upset
that Paul Ryan isn't running for
re-election because many of them see
Ryan as a sort of non Trump friendly
force in the Republican Party so I think
many of them would actually cheer it
send me your thoughts what do you think
that Paul Ryan's retirement resignation
call it what you will means about the
2018 midterm elections and even more
broadly sort of about the future of the
Trump presidency I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show today's episode of the
David Pakman show is made possible in
part by Cody which is an innovative new
cryptocurrency and online payment
platform that is setting out to
revolutionize how we send and receive
online payments the same way that the
transportation industry has been
innovated by ride-sharing apps the same
way that music and video distribution
have been revolutionized by real-time
streaming Cody says that the payment
industry is ripe for transformation
right now Cody stands for currency of
the internet and they're setting out to
make their cryptocurrency which was
designed specifically to be used for
payments that will be the first crypto
if they succeed used on a widespread
mainstream basis for online payments
this will be payment system that can be
used by anyone whether you're a consumer
or a business and regardless of the
industry that you're in most Kryptos
fail to meet the everyday needs of
average consumers or businesses and many
crypto currencies just weren't built
with convenient and trustworthy payment
as their sort of primary function and
this is the specific niche that Cody is
trying to fill with the technology that
they've created if you're watching this
on youtube you can find out more about
Cody and their ICO in the links below
the video this is not financial advice
and you should do all of your own
research before making any investment
decisions